even though one piece is undoubtedly one
of the greatest stories of all time in
every beloved series that goes on for a
long long time there are parts that are
confusing frustrating or straight up
don't make any sense that's right here
are the 20 biggest plot holes in one
piece rank from some minor hilarious
inconsistencies to the biggest
controversies that almost broke the fan
base and actually starting with the very
first chapter of One Piece where Shanks
gets his arm bitten off by a pretty weak
sea monster while saving Luffy and while
this no doubt is an incredibly cool
moment if we look at everything we know
about Shanks at this point in time there
is absolutely no way that he should have
lost his arm here I mean we see much
weaker characters than Shanks take out
enormous sea creatures all the time even
Luffy takes out this very same monster
when he first starts his journey and we
do now know that Shanks at this point in
the story already had a bouncy of over 1
billion berries and we just recently saw
how truly overpowered Shanks is when he
defeated Captain kids however what is
interesting is that we were told in an
interview that Oda was only convinced to
make Shanks lose his arm by one of his
editors in order to make the climax of
that first chapter a little bit more
dramatic and so it definitely didn't
make any sense for Shanks to have lost
his arm unless he did it of course to
inspire Luffy that since Oda didn't
originally plan to do it it still really
stands out as a massive inconsistency
and speaking of Master plans vivi's plan
to infiltrate the criminal organization
Baroque Works has just never made any
sense either we first meet the alabaster
princess in chapter 103 where she's
undercover as the special agent Miss
Wednesday but come on I mean what kind
of secret organization can't tell that
these two are the exact same person
especially since their leader the
warlord crocodile is trying to take over
her own home country and is plotting
against her royal family however this is
nothing compared to the ridiculously
small role that Bounty posters actually
play in the story I mean think about it
the one piece world is full of pirates
most of whom have bounties issued by the
world governments but we have basically
never seen anyone really try to
seriously collect a bounty and honestly
what's even the point of having a bouncy
for monstrous Fighters like big mom
kaido and shangspee's sides just having
something really cool for the fans to
power scale so not so much a plot hole
but more of a missed opportunity I think
to do something really cool with the
whole concept of bounty posters
especially because there is so much
beloved by fans which actually brings me
to another major inconsistency that has
always bothered me for a while now emu
Joy boy and rocks diesel back are
arguably the three most important
characters in the entire story outside
of Luffy and yet all three of these were
introduced super late into the story and
wait wait before you say that this isn't
a plot hole technically let me explain
emu is the secret ruler of the entire
world of the world government joyboy was
a mysterious leader of the ancient
Kingdom during the white century and
Roxy's back was a pirate who tried to
take over the entire world nearly 40
years ago and his crew was stronger than
any other out there and while we assumed
that joyboy is death the introduction of
rocks at especially emu made a lot of
fans who've also seen Naruto go into
heavy sweats as they imagined another
situation like this one and while I do
trust oder to make these characters work
in the story it is a bit weird that
literally almost no one in the world
should know about rocks I mean yes the
government cleansed the history but I
mean powerful Pirates are famous in the
world of one piece for a reason so
wouldn't at least some people around the
world know about the captain of the
strongest pirate crew ever as for our
next plot hole just look at this Zorro
is half the size of this massive chat
here Kazuki Odin but somehow they both
use this exact same sword perfectly fine
and if you've been following one piece
for a while you'll probably know that
this isn't the only example of weird
size issues in the story one piece has
many outrageous character designs and
sizes in fact I actually just made a
video where I compared the smallest
characters all the way to the biggest
things in one piece but sometimes we get
other ridiculous examples like this
Marine Captain who is almost twice as
tall as Luffy talking to one of the
guards of the underwater prison in pull
down who supposedly is over three meters
tall himself now they are officially
only two feet different in height but
just look at all of these panels here
this Jailer is twice as tall as the
Marine so while we love oda's creative
designs it can be a little bit hard to
keep track of the sizes in one piece the
next one is really easy to keep up with
though as it's a giant meme in the
entire Community the infamous five
flying devil fruits in case you don't
know what I'm talking about back in
chapter 169 of One Piece we're being
told that this guy has one of only five
flying type devil fruits that exist in
the worlds only five huh yeah without
even going into anything else if we just
name the ones that actually have wings
there is pel Marco the Phoenix these
Buck devil fruit users this guy with
angel wings a flying dinosaur and a guy
that can turn into a flock of Krause but
of course on top of that there are many
other fruits who don't necessarily have
wings but can easily fly because of
their devil fruits like kaido Robin and
basically anyone else who has eaten a
lokia devil fruit heck there's even this
guy who can fly using his books so maybe
Oda only had five in mind back when he
wrote that chapter or maybe he's
specifically meant that only some Zone
devil fruits give you wings but either
way it has become a real joke throughout
the story for a reason which is
definitely not something you can say
about the Heavy Hitters coming up in
this list as well and speaking of Heavy
Hitters next in the ranking is devil
fruits that should be even more broken
than they already are for example this
terrifying little girl who can literally
turn people into toys that are then
completely forgotten by everyone they
knew just by touching them or lost devil
fruit which basically lets you do
whatever you want to someone within your
surgical room or this one of Samurai's
fruit that lets anything that you draw
literally come to life clones weapons
basically anything if you are a skilled
artist and the Admiral keither was light
fruit which should let him travel around
the world multiple times in a single
second I mean these are just some insane
powers that don't really scale in the
story at all as they should now there
has been an extra explanation in the
story for why certain powers like laws
and sugars aren't even more powerful
than they should be and that's because
we're told by law himself that his
powers are limited by the haki Mastery
of another person in other words if
someone has way stronger hockey then
some Powers won't work on them simply
but then we can simply ask ourselves
what if someone like Zorro who has
incredible Advanced conquerors hockey
eight sugars devil fruit instead I mean
just imagine Zorro coming after you
saying that he'll turn into a little toy
sword unless you subscribe to this
Channel and even though we do know some
things about devil fruits there are
still incredible Mysteries around them
however one common confusion is how much
devil fruit users are affected by water
and this is something many people think
is a plot hole but is actually not and
that's because Oda has explained that a
devil fruit user will only lose all of
their strength and sync if they are
mostly submerged in water and so even
though we see some characters standing
in water up to the hips like Boa Hancock
in the bathtub they can still move
around sounds just fine also devil fruit
users don't lose their entire Powers at
once in water but just gradually as
we've seen for example Luffy's still
stretch and even use red hawk when
completely underwater although we do
have one example of a devil fruit user
not sinking in water when he absolutely
should when Mr three is somehow able to
float in crocodile's flooded prison
instead of sinking whoopsie and while Mr
three probably should have drowned here
next is a character who actively tried
to die but failed every single time
because he is just way too powerful back
in chapter 795 we are fully introduced
to the Emperor kaido who claims to be
trying to kill himself by jumping off a
sky island but hold on a second if he
really wanted to die why didn't he just
jump into the ocean I mean unless he's a
Fishman which he isn't or he has some
other way to breathe underwater he
should just drown right so that seems
like a fairly simple solution that
apparently kaido himself never thought
of and this next one is going to
literally cause you to lose your mind so
make some deep breaths and squeeze your
favorite stress ball because we are
about to bring up one of the community's
least favorite topics in one piece
Amnesia and this isn't really a plot
hole but more of a plot convenience
which a lot of fans hate to see in the
story it first came up when Luffy's
brother Sabo had forgotten Luffy and Ace
at this entire previous life until he's
suddenly very conveniently remembered
them when he saw that Ace died in the
newspaper but as the second in command
of the Revolutionary Army shouldn't he
have known about Ace who was a famous
pirate in the grand line and big mom's
Amnesia and wano caused such heated
controversy that some content creators
even stopped covering one piece for a
while so again while technically not a
plot hole still something we really
don't want to see in the story but
nothing compared to the number one item
coming up in this lists and would you
believe that there is a character who
has leveled up even more than Luffy
since the start of the story as
unbelievable as it is just look at
Marine Captain Kobe's glow up from
chapter 2 to the current storyline right
now he went from scrubbing decks for a
weak pirate to going up against Emperors
of the sea I mean just what kind of
training did GARP put him through for
this to happen but now get ready because
so far in this ranking everything has
just been a relatively minor
inconsistency or a little mistake but
now we're getting into the real
controversial topics off this list you
know the ones that people bring up most
when complaining about one piece and
with some of them I do have to admit
there some a valid criticism here and so
the next crazy plot hole is a problem
both in one piece and in our favorite
social media platform Twitter because
there are many examples in one piece
where it makes no sense that a character
or group doesn't know something that
they absolutely should for example the
world government has a whole agency
devoted to spying but somehow they don't
understand that Chopper is more than
just a straw hats crew's pet even though
yes that is for comic relief but still
and another glaring piece of
misinformation is about the sky islands
I mean basically no one in the world has
heard of The Sky Islands except for
apparently all of the Pirates who've
been there I mean just look at this
example we've seen in the story so far
Roger Pirates kaido a member of the
worst generation and even Bellamy made
it up there sometime after he was
stomped by Luffy and Jaya so if that
many people can get up there and there
even seems to be a main entrance
somewhere in the new world then it
shouldn't be such a major mystery or
legend that they exist but this is
nothing compared to how badly the world
seems to be misinformed about devil
fruits I mean despite many of the most
famous pirates and Marines all being
devil fruit users there are still Parts
in the one piece world where people
think that these fruits are some sort of
Legends and yes while you can argue that
the majority of devil fruit users can be
found on the grand line surely they
shouldn't be so mysterious as they are
especially with newspaper deliveries
available basically anywhere in the
world and as much as devil fruits remain
mysterious even more confusing is the
next plot hole here who the hell has
actually awakened their devil fruits has
this guy we don't know but we know that
these Jailer beasts and even those world
government agents have now if you don't
know Awakening a devil fruit is the
ultimate power up for a devil fruit user
but there appears to be something
about some characters who definitely
at least have awakened their fruits but
have apparently not done so because for
all Zone devil fruit users like Luffy
the world government agents and even
kaido's child Yamato when they awaken
the devil fruits they get this
clout-like scarf around their necks
however there are other confirmed
awakened Zone fruit users such as the
Jailer Beast of people down and possibly
even Chopper who do not have this scarf
and even kaido himself doesn't have that
sort of scarf in his hybrid form so why
is that is kaido just a special case
because of his fruit and is it for the
jailers and Chopper because they're like
not truly awakened but kind of the
animal got control over them it's not
really clear please fix that Oda but
regardless of that we'll actually be
talking more about kaido in the number
one plot hole on this list and this next
one nearly cost Luffy his life that's
because during the baratia arc Sanji did
not know that devil fruit users can't
swim and he almost lets Luffy drown
however just a while later in Thriller
bark we do learn that as a child Sanji
actually read the legendary devil fruit
encyclopedias and you're telling me that
this famous Encyclopedia of of devil
fruits does not contain the number one
weakness of those magical powers I mean
who wrote this thing that was probably
zoro's ancestor for being real oh but uh
this next Plateau comes with a really
important question would you rather live
on a giant snail or an Island full of
broccoli well I do hope that you chose
the giant snail because the broccoli
Island stands apparently no chance in
the fight with the snail because of this
next giant plot hole that's because
technology in one piece is a major
inconsistency some kingdoms like the
germa and the world government fight
with super powered futuristic clones and
laser beams while other kingdoms fight
with sticks and Spears and this has
always been an issue but technology
advancement varies incredibly throughout
the one piece world and even though it
doesn't really make sense admittedly it
is kind of part of the charm of one
piece for me it is such a unique and
varied world and we do love the story
because of it plus the world government
probably does suppressed technology it
still seems kind of odd that some groups
have so much and others have so little
and no one is talking to each other also
why is Morgan's the only one who has
ever made an actual flying machine I
mean seriously alright on to the top
five here so get ready with your popcorn
as we get to the biggest plot holes in
the story that we love starting with why
did the world's government actually
tried to kill Luffy when he was a weaker
Pirates I mean in chapter 1044 the same
chapter that Luffy awakens gear 5 we
learned that the leaders of the world
government have known the true nature of
Luffy's devil fruit all along and if you
really is such a Monumental threat to
them why didn't they just eliminate him
I mean to be fair they have always
wanted Luffy dead and even send
ridiculously powerful people to do it
like Kuma Thriller bark then Admiral
aokiji found him after skypeia and Kizer
who had multiple chances to kill him in
Saba ODI and on Marine forts but
never really gone all out to try and
kill Luffy and you can say that they
didn't want to make a big deal of the
devil fruit which we'll talk more about
coming up from spoiler warning or that
they were simply too naive to do it but
remember the world government has been
in power for 800 years so they have to
be pretty good at their job right which
makes this Choice a pretty big oversight
that was never really Justified except
of course for the story purposes and
while the world's government failed to
kill Luffy another incredible plot hole
is all the times that Luffy should have
actually died in the story now it is
true that the main characters have some
sort of plot armor that keeps them alive
no matter what because it is their story
even in a bloody masterpiece like Attack
on Titan the main character survived
basically everything again would not be
a story if the main character is not
around but Luffy really should have died
in the second chapter when his little
boat got caught in that whirlpool and
again when captured by this clown and
the Marine captains there were multiple
times that he should have died against
the warlord crocodile like when he was
literally impaled poisoned and thrown
into quicksands also Marine Admiral
should have killed him multiple times
this secret agent could have easily done
it after the first fight in water 7 or
while Luffy was in the underwater prison
imple down and so on and so forth
should make a whole video about that huh
but somehow Luffy always lifts and you
can call this his ability to make
friends or his determination fade but at
the end of the day some people will
always feel less tension in the story
when the main characters can't survive
pretty much anything and one of the main
reasons that Luffy did not die during
the pre-time skip is because of this
next plot hole but why would hockey not
really a thing during pre-time skip
again I mean hockey is essentially the
power of a person's will there are three
kinds and the first two anyone in the
world can easily learn first is
observation hockey which allows you to
sense attacks and people around you
second is Armament hockey which allows a
character to coat their body with a
sword of armor and only some people in
the world with exceptionally strong
Wills can use the third one Congress
hockey now this power allows its user to
easily dominate weak-willed individuals
and eventually allows them to even
enhance their physical attacks to the
highest level basically if you want to
be a top tier fighter in one piece you
need some sort of high-level hockey or
best of it all three however there are
so many instances in pre-time skin one
piece where a character should have
known and should have used hockey but
they did not for example some of the
strongest government secret agents never
learned how to use hockey whitebeards
and no weekends never bothered to use
hockey to block random bullets and
swords at Marine Forts and while hints
of it were shown on rare occasions like
Mantra and skypeia in general it was not
utilized at all and consistently by
powerful characters especially early on
in the story now some people justify
this because Luffy didn't know hockey so
he wasn't perceiving it and neither were
weave through his eyes but this story is
not being told through Luffy's eyes so
that doesn't exactly explain it more
likely is that Oda did not fully have
the plan and idea for hockey worked out
until years into the story so it wasn't
included so much in the pre-time skip
arcs but now onwards to the top two here
coming in just behind the most hated
plot hole is the reveal of Luffy's true
devil fruit Powers now this is a huge
huge controversy that we've covered
before on on this channel essentially
Luffy's devil fruit is not the rubber
fruit as we're told in chapter 1 but
rather it's a mythical Zone God Nika
devil fruit that basically lets Luffy
manifest his imagination into reality
now there are two sides to this debate
first some people believe that Oda had
this plant ever since the start of the
story which to be fair there have been a
lot of hints for Luffy using unusual
powers throughout one piece like Redhawk
which lets him punch with fire or how he
can bend rubber in ways that should not
be possible like with snakemen and of
course there are some other hints like
this famous panel during skypeia that
hints at Luffy being special but on the
other hand many fans also felt that Oda
just needed to make the story feel a
little bit more interesting and decided
to change this fruit near the end of the
story not on a whim but you know what I
mean pretty late on into the game now
whatever the reason one thing that will
always bother me is why people who the
true powers of this fruit didn't do more
to stop or help Luffy with it like the
government not going all out to kill
their biggest threat or why Shanks would
risk Luffy dying and the devil fruit
falling into the wrong hands once again
after going through so much trouble of
getting it but not only that there are
also an incredible amount of future plot
holes based on his powers of imagination
for example what is the limit to Luffy's
ability to change the world I mean we do
know that he has an endless imagination
so could he change the world itself with
the snap of his fingers faith anoda I'm
sure we'll figure it out but now number
one and the most frequently raged about
part of the story
bake out deaths and uh by fake out
deaths we mean when Oda creates an
emotional scene where it looks like a
character has really died under tragic
circumstances just for that character to
later on reappear perfectly fine no
scratch now just some examples here are
Pell who sacrificed himself tragically
by taking a bomb out of alabaster this
guy who took a full Lightning Blast from
NL was just fine this Samurai who was
literally cleaved into two parts and
then just reappeared running around the
castle and many many many other and you
know it's not like Oda Never Kills a
character there have been deaths such as
of course Whitebeard and Ace during
marineford of course and countless
deaths during flashbacks but he just has
a really really hard time killing
characters in the present story even the
main enemies of wano kaido and big mom
were defeated and thrown into an actual
volcano but there are dozens of theories
about how they actually could have
survived this because we've just such a
hard time believing that Oda will
actually kill somebody please order just
kill some people so while you could call
as a plot hole it really is just a
frustrating Choice by Oda to
consistently give us these fake out
deaths some readers have just accepted
that Oda does this but it does create an
actual problem for the story itself
because it dramatically decreases
tension of any major fight when you can
seriously believe that there are any
risks for any of the characters you care
about not only talking about Luffy here
and so deaths are a really rare
appearance in one piece but that does
not mean that Luffy never loses in fact
he actually loses a lot and if you want
to see the surprisingly long list of
everyone who has ever defeated Luffy in
the story well you can watch this video
right here thanks for watching